ob selbst gefahren sie gerade mit das
land gegen die wand sowie hellem exakt
kann sich ja nicht ganz sicher nicht ich
will ihnen sagen wie ich zum beispiel
auf die unionbrücke weil er huber ja
immer wieder fragt wie das ähnlich wie
der koalition aussehen diese union ist
angetreten mit dem finanzpolitischen
programms zur bundestagswahl dass
mindereinnahmen wegen wegfall des soli
wegen senkung der unternehmenssteuern
von 33 milliarden euro vorsah
gleichzeitig mehr ausgaben allein für
rüstung 25 milliarden obendrauf
deckungsvorschläge 0 das aber umgehende
rückkehr als der schuldenbremse und zur
schwarzen null ist das finanzpolitisch
seriös ist das ein programm mit dem 7
diese gesellschaft vorne zu bringen ich
will ihnen sagen das ist ein programm
mit dem man glaubt die leute verstehen
zu koennen aber nicht dass es so was von
unseriös gewesen wie nur irgendwas und
ich bin nur froh dass die union keine
gelegenheit hat ein solch unsinniges und
kontraproduktives programm in politik
umsetzen zu können herr huber sagt dass
man sich islam verscharrt wie habe
selbst gesagt
also ich glaube wer hat das land
verteilt ist die ampel koalition die
jeden tag einen anderen vorschlag bringt
und sich über diese vorschläge streitet
christian lindner als angetreten mit dem
versprechen der finanzpolitischen
stabilität und ist der größte
schuldenmacher seit jahrzehnten und
darüber hinaus möchte ich auch nochmal
anführen war selbst als gehe auch dann
ins feld führt die ampel ist in allen
zentralen punkten intern zerstritten im
prinzip steht die ampel in meinen augen
auf tönernen füßen sie werden kaum eine
position finden die von allen drei
andere parteien geteilt wird abschluss
gehabt die bundeswehr angesprochen was
ist das für ein hick-hack in der
ampelkoalition über das von olaf scholz
angekündigte sondervermögen also die
ampel sollte erst mal ihre hausaufgaben
machen und klären wofür sie steht wie
wurde mit dem finger auf andere zeigt
warum schlagen sich in die büsche warum
stehen sie nicht zu dem was sie
programmatisch bundestagswahl gefordert
haben das war genau das was ich wieder
gegeben habe das ist sowas von unseriös
das uns auch unternehmer an man kann
sagte beck
um die bürger frau boss macht nehmen sie
uns
die große klammer diese genau die
übrigen preise beim tanken im supermarkt
was sind sie bereit noch für einen liter
benzin zu bezahlen an der tankstelle ich
glaube das ist völlig falsche frage ich
werde so oder so tun müssen weil ich
hier auf dem land wohnen ich bin auf
mein auto angewiesen
die nächste bushaltestelle ist 50
gehminuten entfernt das hat mich müssen
team die fragen was ich bezahlen will
muss ich bereit bin wenn ich werde das
so lang bezahlen wie ich es tun muss
weil ich keine alternative punkt ganz
kurze antwort womit rechnet sie privat
geht es hoch 250 260 zweier ja die also
um mehr als 260 gehe ich von aus nicht
weil ich wusste wenn es vielleicht das
ganze realistisch der wird kaum zu
prognostizieren hier weitergeht ich bin
selbst wenn ist der temporäre
erleichterungen geben wird erinnert des
jahres oder dann zum herbst denn ich
sehe da ziemlich schwarz
schneider ist dass die frage die frage
der inflation die frage der preise die
die nächsten wahlen entscheiden wird und
wann welche waren sie mal waren
september glaube ich niedersachsen
wählen dann wird es auf jeden fall schon
eine große rolle spielen ist klar das
ist auch die ferien rum also hat eine
gewaltige sprengkraft dieser hat spät
kam wir müssen wirklich sehen ich kann
es nur noch mal sagen was frau bosbach
vorhin so gewarnt hat vor weiteren
entlastungsprogramm
und hilfen im moment keine
volkswirtschaftlichen schule weiß halten
sondern wir müssen jetzt dringend zur
kenntnis nehmen wir haben millionen von
menschen die wissen nicht mehr wie sie
das monatsende erreichen sollen und das
sind menschen die durchaus auch arbeiten
das sind viele alleinerziehende frauen
die vollzeit arbeiten können wir haben
ich kann es noch mal wiederholen wir
haben millionen von menschen die sind
auf lebensmittelspenden mittlerweile
angewiesen wir brauchen natürlich
entlastungsprogramm aber zielgenau für
diese person und dann auch so dass ich
über dich mit komm her damit deutschland
nicht auseinanderbrechen